Are there any topical things to do to help with benign tumors that are close to the skin surface, or what else would could someone use to try to get rid of a single solid benign tumor that is a pleomorphic adenoma of the prodigal.
So, getting rid of solid tumors, so there's a difference between different tumors, but I tumors, some could be fluid filled, some could be solid tumors.
Can you get rid of solid tumors without doing surgery? So, I know a pleomorphic adenoma of the prodigal is almost always going to be treated with surgery.
You're surgically exercising that. Is that a bad thing? I really don't think so. What if somebody can't do surgery for whatever reason? What are some other things to do? Can you use topical things?
It's going to be very hard for a topical to get down to that. I know people who have used topical things, something that's close to the surface and used DMSL as a driver over a bad thing.
So, that is something that you could think of. What would you use topically on a tumor like that? Again, you would just try to kill that tumor.
That would be without testing that it would be really hard to say. I can't really give you specifically what you would use for that.
We have used the right of benign tumors with actually great success. When I first had a patient come to me and said they had a benign, I think it was a giant cell tumor.
That was about, I think it was 13, 14 centimeters large of their amperelet. I wasn't quite sure how it was going to work, how the right was going to work.
But they had referred by a cancer patient and I said, I don't know if this is going to work or not. I wrote a program for get it.
I think the last time I spoke there was down to three centimeters so it's kind of just been staying at that.
So, it can work for a lot of different things. That's what they would try if you were totally against surgery.
I do know the surgery for those are pretty simplistic as far as surgery is going to be in a very high success rate.